j'ai rompu avec adrian
j'ai vraiment cru à fond que ce serait
lui personne d'autre et les buts être
temps de faire une pause
de prendre du temps pour toi seul
salut
ça va ça faisait longtemps suis content
tournoi
il y à un moment de ma vie où tout ce
que je veux c'est parcourir le monde et
découvrir de nouvelles cultures et c'est
ça qui transforme
[Musique]
mais plus vieux pote c'est le genre de
mec et l'ambiance il est marrant
j'ai tout tenté
lui qui exactement
[Musique]
je t'explique j'aime beaucoup de jack
mais je peux pas faire comme si je te
connaissais pas maman tu sais que moi
complètement dingue
je tiens vraiment pas à [ __ ] la merde
dans votre amitié tout va bien se passer
il s'est passé autre chose entre vous ce
soir là je suis fatigué de faire du mal
aux jo
[Musique]
et
dans un mois du mois oublier fusion fais
quoi moi c'est affolant
[Musique]
et
fait
jouer
il se pourrait que tout ne soit pas
parfait
et
savait rien
[Musique]